[Music]
so the bartender says to the gorilla uh
you'll have to excuse me i don't mean to
offend you but we don't get many
gorillas in here and the gorilla looks
at the bartender and says well at 20
martini i'm not surprised
hey everyone what's up welcome back to
the lobby i'm mike mccarty your host
i was pretty sick of the what's up
everyone welcome back to
the lobby game spots weekly video game
hangout it was getting stale figured i'd
finish off that joke that i started
during that intro pre-roll what's up i'm
glad everybody can join us
uh this is pete brown back from where
were you portland
ah oregon yes how was that birthday
weekend right yeah it was great um
girlfriend did a lot of shopping which
made her happy which then made me feel
comfortable about
dropping some money on a big game yeah
and looking at it for a while second
saturn game panzer dragoon saga i
finally have it was like unopened no no
oh god i don't know this stuff that
would be thousands of dollars uh no it
was great a lot of good food uh saw some
snow so oh so what you spent was
reasonable is what you're telling me
yeah cause yeah my girlfriend offered to
split it because she's awesome cool
well happy birthday wait when is your
birthday it was monday
oh no 32 years young
i'm saying that now because you got it
you've got a year on me
happy birthday eric hey this is your
first time in the new lobby set but you
work on every single lobby episode
currently you've been in the lobby i
have not it's pretty funny every time
you're on people in the chat are always
like oh they're probably talking about
destiny and
fair we're talking about dustin it's the
3ds right it's destiny division or
diablo usually anyways yeah
three three details
yeah here we are on the lobby you can
watch it in 3d now which is pretty cool
just kidding
what's up hey hi you're here all the
time i i yeah i'm usually here you also
like destiny a lot i do pretty much play
a lot of destiny we have both of our
destiny experts i like the panel today i
like shooting stuff in space that's kind
of my thing yeah we got the uh teaser
image i'll get into the newsreel that
teaser image released for destiny 2. uh
it leaked a while ago there's that
poster from like an italian website
leaked it lego.com
it's like no it's lego lego thank you
long syllable at the end i use the
masculine form of the word sorry um
but anyway yeah we do have some pretty
cool stuff going on today uh hunter
pence the right fielder for our hometown
san francisco giants is gonna be in two
stream mlb 17 with our uh nick margarita
so they will be doing that right at 12
30 p.m yep pacific time uh so we will
finish up the lobby at a reasonable time
so you guys can all get ready for that
expect hijinks yeah if even if you're
not super into sports games uh which we
don't really talk about on this show
that's fine because i'm sure nick
margarita will screw it up somehow no
i'm just i'm joking i'm just joking nick
margarita and hunter pence are both very
entertaining people uh they're gonna be
doing some create a character uh
shenanigans and i'm sure i'll watch it
so stick around after the lobby for that
uh and then as usual the triforce or no
sorry just triforce our zelda breath of
the wild stream show with rob handlery
and this year pete brown will be
tomorrow at what time 11 o'clock cool in
the morning and i'm sure gamespot will
be tweeting and reminding everybody but
that about that but that'll be on twitch
youtube uh you can catch up on that it's
just they kind of take an hour every
week to try
doing new stuff in zelda but with the
end game of eventually in the long run
killing ganon right yeah maybe
we'll see what happens we'll see
uh and don't forget she's got ghost in
the shell coming up oh yeah you're
watching goes to the shell tonight yes
i'm seeing ghosts in the shell um if you
subscribe to gamespot universe on
youtube um we'll have
several things going up around that so
if you're interested in that movie or
the anime
then check it out
cool uh yeah you and chastity vacencio
will be going tonight right yeah a
couple of anime girls cool the best
girls sweet
uh we
let's get right into the news reel uh we
do have a giveaway and also something a
news item that's related to that uh
mafia three there's a free trial
releasing and then alongside the new del
c coming out so
do we get to we've had these in our uh
margarita memorial library for a while
uh here i'll have you guys model that
it's a collection it's actually pretty
cool uh it comes with
the that like an mp3 slash vinyl player
it comes with the vinyl what size is
that vinyl do you remember you would
know this better than i would pete it's
probably it was a smaller one oh seven
inch seven inch vinyl uh don't take my
word for that but there is a vinyl with
like eight songs from the soundtrack for
this game
um you can play that and it works and
you can also hook up your phone through
like an auxiliary port uh we have one of
these in the office but we only have
xbox one unfortunately the ps4 one we
did an unboxing for or when this game
released back in
oh sweet thank you john luke i mean my
dog tags on
yeah that's everything right there
that's the splayed out image
hopefully he'll take this photo down in
a second no no thank you
uh
yeah so today game's probably tweeting
uh about this giveaway you can uh follow
gamespot and retweet said tweet and then
later in the week it will pick a winner
uh if you want this for xbox one maybe
we'll win it so do that
cool
uh also
oh
in other news
uh destiny 2 teaser image we're going to
be getting into destiny 2 later on for a
segment but the destiny 2 teaser image
officially released there's no official
release date from bungie yet although
there's a leaked one and everything up
to this point has been true based on
those leaks so
we will see we will get more into the
game later what we want from destiny 2.
we don't really have any concrete
evidence we know just as much as you do
but we want to get into that later on uh
and that's pretty much it
but now you know what i want to talk
about
i want to talk about everything sweet
everything anything and everything
yeah someone hit me with something let's
talk about it
anything everything
the game everything
last week or two weeks ago for ps4 uh i
played a good deal amount of it last
week on ps4
this is a weird game we want to talk
about what kind of game it is and what
you do in it and
what is going on i haven't played it for
what i understand though you can embody
anything
and everything pretty much up to the
galactic level on the on the upper tier
or on the molecular level oh my god
yeah look at that bear go so yeah that's
how everything moves in the game um
in your time did you find that this
expression
amounts to anything it does not it
didn't get old yet because
you start
in this in a tutorial area and you go
around so you don't always start as the
same animal so i started as an oxen in
the desert
and i was walking around talking to
rocks and palm trees and
little mesas and they were telling me
uh what was going on because i had no
idea yeah
and they were just saying some some of
these haikus that were explaining what
was happening and then i was hoarding up
with other oxen and speeding up as you
can see they're doing here with these
black bears oh so but then and i know
the answer but what is the point
uh
you know the answer good i know please
tell me because i don't know
i
you
it's just exploring and kind of what is
the end objective you mean
no what's the point of it all mike uh
why why would you engage in this game
just to explore and be different things
i mean look you can be is it not to
understand your place in the universe i
guess so and you see different
perspectives i was gonna say isn't
asking what the point of this game the
point of this game exactly um also the
title is super weird for seo like i
don't know how you how do you google
everything game
um
but yeah it's it's really interesting
i've been following this game for a
while because when i first heard of it i
was like wait you can inhabit a coffee
cup you can inhabit a banana you can do
anything um
but i know there's like some
sound bites from a british philosopher
whose name is escaping what yes and i
feel like that would get really i don't
like heavy-handed stuff like that i
don't know what have you i haven't
encountered any of that yet i listened
to a little bit of it in the video
coverage we have and he basically starts
going on like okay you know we look at
animals as just animals right but
to them if you imagine what you know how
we consider ourselves human animals
think that they're human not like
us but an equivalent in their eyes and
so it's experiencing these perspectives
of everything
that you know where
anything can literally feel like it's
important and have a place in the world
and it just depends on your scale and
you know perspective and location and
all that so i've not gone down to this
molecular level here i went up so the
galaxy is the highest you can go you
can't go past into like uh
what's after that like a star cluster no
star clusters in a galaxy whatever you
can't go to like a universal level
because they wouldn't be able to show
that uh but
eventually you know you could be a
continent you could be icy landmass and
then you can go across the ocean come up
to
a
desert land mass and then you can go
down into the molecular level of that
desert land mass passing through camels
and rocks and mesas and palm trees and
a lot of things and i haven't inhabited
anything man-made yet but
this gameplay trailer this is a gameplay
trailer watching from a playstation blog
i believe a few months ago you can like
inhabit a spaceship it looked like later
on in this uh and what by trailer i mean
like gameplay trailer but goals
would you say life goals yeah
you can
it looked like you could be a spaceship
and then it's funny when you're a plant
you don't uh move around as like a herd
or anything you actually just kind of
grow in a line like a new tree will pop
up
in a set path and here you see this
camel is kind of in this weird
deciduous forest joining up with other
camels
with strange markings
and now you see an oak tree and now
you're a pretty you're a rose
uh if you're a continent can you cause
an earthquake
i don't know like a tsunami across the
ocean yeah can you just like really mess
everything up that'd be pretty cool as
long as you're not hurting anyone
do the hearts actually signify anything
or is it just when you like switch to
something else uh no those are when you
uh when you're an animal you can group
up with other similar animals uh here's
a land mass so you see it moving across
the ocean expanse unrealistic yeah
dang
you can see this is running on uh unreal
fort no i'm just kidding um
this game is it was weird i think it was
i kind of grouped it and rob hanley
brought this up after playing abzu last
year yeah or i don't know i brought up
the flower
or journey comparisons almost and it's
kind of meditative playing this game
right because here you become
a
life-supporting planet
i mean they don't call it earth i don't
believe this does have like an auto play
mode right where you can just sort of
let it do its own thing oh i don't know
i didn't do that yeah there uh has
andrew over at playstation uh andrew
kelly he uh was tweeting about that uh
which sounds kind of interesting like i
almost might like just to have it on at
my desk just to have like this weird
biome thing going on next to me blue
drago in the youtube chat just said if i
wanted science i'll go and get a book
right there with you oh i had fun with
this oh eric green and youtube's kind of
got a good point it's like
it pretty much is kind of like i am uh i
am bread right except you're just other
stuff and you can just keep changing
into other stuff i mean like there's
obviously a little bit more complexity
to it but well they definitely try to
rope in like philosophy is a big part of
it um
i mean that's the part that gives me pop
because like that's the part i i like
least about the witness for example is
when you like have to start listening to
all the philosophy and i was like no i
was thinking my own philosophy i was
having my own thoughts
yeah and so i think it's interesting
it's sort of like an art installation i
think is how gamespot's reviewer
described it um but i think it's it
would be better left
to you kind of reflecting on in oh if it
is about how everything in the world is
interconnected then that's for you to
extrapolate from it i don't need
somebody to tell me that and i don't
need to have the philosophy fed to me
right you know it's kind of telling and
not showing yeah i think that's what
disrupts the the cool nate like the
interesting thing about it for me
because it's like oh you know i don't
think i would ever spend too much time
with this but the
if i spent you know 30 minutes with it
that time is valuable
um from what i can
use garlic cloves
can also just be silly
but um yeah i don't know
it's
it's strange to me it feels nice
unfinished or something like an
unfinished thought
my concern is that because there's so
much to be
uh it's overwhelming me in the sense
that no man sky did it first i was like
what's the point of seeing anything if
you could see everything
i don't know okay here we go um clearly
some cooper made that barrel uh and then
you can transfer into a lion
that
the design choice to make them move like
that
i wonder what's behind that it's got to
be just as a joke or it
it i can only assume otherwise that it's
a means to just get this game out
that works
lion growing just
yes what on earth
as a lion will
for those just joining this is uh the uh
desert level from call of duty 2. no
this is everything
uh an odd game it's part of the the play
collective sony's do in the spring with
uh i don't know it's not like artistic
games only because rain world is a part
of it as well but certainly like
offbeat
experience it's definitely experimental
um
i oh my gosh this is so distracting i
can't handle it yeah give me more i need
it that's another thing that's weird to
me is like if it is for comedic effect
like if it is sort of breaking down um
traditional mechanics the way something
like like i am bread which eric green in
the youtube chat brought up um
it's weird it's at odds with the
more kind of reflective introspective uh
philosophical stuff and that's what's
weird to me yeah i think but also like
when your plants or when they show those
butterflies it looks pretty beautiful
the way they're moving and uh these
sperm cells here as you can see i don't
know what what else would you call them
those are not
swimmers oh my god well i know what else
you would call sperm cells saying what
else would those be
uh here we go turtles i like those um
shut up
you set it up and uh
you looped me on that one oh here we go
so now we're getting into more uh
man-made what was that art movie about
the pr uh coy on the scottish yeah
i had to watch that for an art writing
class that i took against my will uh
sure and then what do you mean sure i
know you okay and it was super about
like it starts off showing these uh
pastoral sublime kind of landscapes and
all of a sudden there's farms cropping
up and then all of a sudden there's a
city and then there's yeah there's ocean
powerkatsy as well no there's like three
movies in that series they're all a bit
much
okay art school boys i should go to art
school are they talking about i studied
journalism
okay here we have lightning bugs and
fish
oh here we go okay so there i have not
gotten to the point where i was using
man-made stuff i don't know and there's
a spaceship i don't know if that's uh
one of the cases where
that's a matter of playing in like a
matter of time in the game where the
game itself progresses or if i could go
do that right now if i take the right
path through the right number of items
what this looks normal this looks like
uh an eye spy book oh the bear's in
space
oh no is he okay
is he okay
oh jen frog
i don't like insane hypno playing a harp
with a violin that's
sick um this is pretty cool i haven't
seen anything like this before bye
see that's what i'm saying does the
universe deteriorate in this game is it
time sped up
this is
i i have not seen this yet
this is new to all of us at once
and uh yeah no like i said the uh the
lsd comes sold separately yeah
so
playstation could not supply that for
you
unfortunately um
i don't know what kind of music would
accompany this well i mean they have
ambient music but what kind of music
would you play for that ragtime
motown soul
that would be weird that game is weird
so the question i want to ask is what
kind of game is this and i'm more
confused now than i was at the beginning
of this segment
it's a
yeah i don't know
it's an introspective game
i mean it's experimental and it's it's
about exploration more than it is
anything i think that's the central
concern it's just like doing
what you feel like doing follow your
heart
yeah on twitter jobo underscore gm asked
is the concept of everything enough to
sustain interest for longer play
durations that's kind of what i was
wondering uh i don't think i would play
this game long for the same reason i'm
playing a lot of persona 5. it would
it's
i'm not feeling rewarded for it again
it's more meditative for me and it's
kind of just seeing what will happen
yeah i mean not every game has to be
something you'll spend a lot of time
with i mean some of my favorite games
are games that
i spent you know an hour with and
it was one and done and then i was like
that was so cool and it made me really
think about a lot of things and i mean i
think this has the potential to do that
but it's
i don't know it's it's a little too
abstract for me i'm kind of like i i
don't know what i'm supposed to be
getting out of this besides being like
whoa molecules are so small i feel like
more than most games you have to be in
the right mindset to play it and get
something out of it yeah hey this game
seems right up your alley
yeah is there is there for gear to farm
yeah can you can you min max these
flowers the universe is the the truest
mmo ah
well
on that note
i don't think i can say anything more
profound than that uh i
kind of
i don't know if i'll play more this game
i want to but i also have a lot of other
games to play and
again i feel like i saw everything
but i know i didn't but i kind of want
to get to the point where i'm inhabiting
these artificial things these ships
these spaceships
vessels if you will thank you
uh but anyway let us know uh if you plan
on playing this amid all the other
releases uh this is available on
playstation and i believe it's coming to
pc soon sure
sick
you tell me i don't know yeah
it is coming to pc soon and you can
check it out on that
let us know what you think about
everything
literally
starcraft remastered got announced this
game's a little more
succinct
rts that's a weird way to describe
starcraft i know well compared to
everything eric yes you like starcraft i
do did you play the original a lot yeah
i played uh the original in brood war a
lot in high school um and i think i felt
like as i was growing up at least for me
i played a lot more rts games than i do
now yeah i don't think that
outside of when starcraft 2 first came
out i've really touched any rts since um
back then with command and conquer and
starcraft and stuff like that and
warcraft um so it's interesting to see
it get remastered but for the longest
time this rumor has been kind of
lingering and you kind of felt like it
was going to happen yeah so i'm just
interested to see
if people still care i guess i mean like
when that game came out uh and maybe
this reflects your experience or not but
like
a lot of lan party situations around
starcraft you know like i used to play
magic and i'd go to my local like game
shop to like you know sit down and play
some cards but there was also like a row
of 12 computers and like
this was the game that i
really identified with as you know
competitive pc gaming like at first like
yeah there was kind of there was like
quake and stuff back then but this this
really kicked it off
um and definitely took off more than
something like command and conquer i
mean there were so many different red
alert and commanding conquer games that
like they all kind of blended together
but starcraft always had its own real
strong identity and for all the series
well for all the series that blizzard
blizzard has exploited this one hasn't
really been i feel like it hasn't been
tapped like
starcraft 2 has been out now for what
six seven years i think something like
that three expansions three expansions
and that's that's kind of it and there
was two expansions for this right
yeah yeah like brood war and yeah i know
it's just brood wars brutal just produce
rewards yeah i feel like there's a lot
of potential maybe people miss down on
this game back in the day well for the
longest time i was joking they're gonna
do
the next mmo for blizzard it's gonna be
space of starcraft you know
yeah that didn't come out either right
yeah
that never officially got canceled but
it's not out how many years later 10. so
it's probably not going to happen it
might though who knows
um starcraft yeah just for uh like
running through the specs uh base game
and brood war that is uh included it's
gonna be 4k ultra high definition which
they showed during that trailer yeah i
mean they show the the wipe kind of and
they showed it to the wider resolution
too right um and then it'll have
matchmaking uh we do have a question
from bob jones is it gamespot regular
but on twitter he was asking how much
will it cost and can i play it offline
uh they have not announced pricing yet
they said it's going to be out this
summer so i'm assuming we'll see more
soon we don't know anything either um in
terms of playing it offline i would
assume you could play the campaign
offline i don't think you yeah i mean i
mean matchmaker but
that and maybe if you could land
possibly yeah but i don't know no one
anymore that's true nobody lands anymore
it was for me land was a halo and then
warcraft 3 the mods tower defense mods
uh winter maul
that was that was the best that was the
peak of my
uh nish tower defense hobby
and then assassin's creed revelations
came along and had tower friends so it
ruined it for me um
i have a question for you sure all right
let's go hit me up with that
i mean peter you were talking about uh
starcraft kind of kicking off uh
competitive piece like what we think of
as competitive pc gaming
does going back to it have the same
effect like does returning to it have
the same value or does it have like what
is the value there i think that
it's not really going to get that many
new people because you probably would
have just played starcraft 2 if you're
going to play an rts i think it's the
nostalgia feeling yeah that like a lot
of people have with starcraft and in
some people's minds they actually like
starcraft and brood war more than
excuse me more than starcraft 2. so i
could see
that potentially coming into play
maybe esports i don't know they're going
to try they're going to try because they
still have yeah i think i i think that
they'll try because they had a lot of
starcraft 2
um
up and coming pros and pros that came
over from the brood war scene sure so
maybe they'll be more like invitationals
or kind of
kind of things like that but yeah um
it's hard to say i did do the land thing
like you did with starcraft and and
counter-strike those two were the games
that were kind of ping-pong between if
we went to a land cafe
and i don't know i don't it's it's a
weird timing i'd rather have that was
just a funny way to say cafe is that
what you're laughing at too no it's
happening
clearly he doesn't know what a land cafe
is
yeah that's like the hardest side quest
in that game it takes all three days i
know
don't bring up that horror
goddamn starcraft conversation uh for
those who don't know oh uh jean lucky
our producer in the back room said that
the trailer did say land support
nice sweet so for those who don't know
what did broodwar do to the base game uh
it basically added a bunch of units
essentially that changed the way the
game works so lurker was a huge one
which is like a sieging unit for the
zerg that you know could burrow and then
you it shoots out kind of like a line of
spikes essentially but you'd have to
have observers or you'd have to scan it
so it made you think more about those
kind of things dark templar for for the
protoss so it just changed how you
thought about the game i guess because
you had to
worry about all these cloaked units that
you didn't have to before
um and kind of adapt your strategies to
that medic was huge for taren because it
could heal your stimmed marines
uh so it's just more of like a meta
thing for the game
uh that's kind of how it changed but i
think broodwar made that game a lot
better
yeah i mean we were saying
when this guy announced
and we were talking about like halo wars
2 came out this year as well and it was
kind of you know lackluster kelly you
reviewed it i did review it you give it
a 6 out of 10. yes yeah i didn't love it
uh it was an okay game but it didn't
like as a halo fan and rts fan i was
kind of hoping for a better blend of
both but i think they kind of went in
both directions didn't have a good
singular identity um i also wanted to
talk about this like kind of current
state of the rts genre because there
aren't a lot
releasing there's a decent amount and
there's some cool interesting games
coming out especially last year but it's
nothing like huge i don't know if
starcraft remastered will be enough to
like kickstart another
generation of these games but
i mean ideally it would but i don't
think it will but
i forgot you live in an ideal world yeah
we need an optimist sitting next to
crummy curmudgeon oh sorry that's a
twitter handle it a gamespot fan crummy
chromatin and i think it's you
it's it's john
uh you were saying but uh i mean
as a
if there was a remaster that i really
want from blizzard it's actually diablo
too yeah i don't think it'll happen but
like everyone's
or not everyone's but some of the people
in the office were immediately like oh
they did starcraft remastered let's just
do diablo 2 remastered because i spent
so much time playing that game and i
think that would be really cool i
thought maybe they'd do it last year
blizzcon because it was the 20th
anniversary for diablo and i don't know
we'll see i'd rather have that than
starcraft remastered but that's just me
it's just weird that going back to the
rts stuff i mean last year was total war
warhammer ash is the singularity
um
homeworld deserts of carrick
uh what was the
off-world trading company uh soren
johnson who did who's a lead designer in
civ 4 he released the off-road training
company which is a really good game it
was one of my it was like top
it was a really good game last year uh
then dawn of war 3 is pretty close on
the horizon um
there there's a decent amount of rts
games coming out in that space
but it doesn't seem like the audience is
there anymore to make them huge right
like you mentioned command and conquer i
have that um
like 15th anniversary edition through
origin and it's
like 18 games or something red alert 2
is one of my favorite games period
and i play that every once in a while
still but i played homeworld last year
that game was great as the singularity
was cool and the the scale that it
portrayed you could zoom out and it
would
you could command like battalions and
also single units and see like an entire
planet
technically impressive off-road training
company was a cool take on uh economy
and how that could transfer into the
real-time strategy genre but
i don't know there's nothing that's
really
you know you see shooters had a
watershed year yeah 2016. uh here you
see the clown from it
or the bellhop from home alone too if
you're into that
i think you know the problem sorry one
more one more herkimer homokov from uh
congo there we go consider sorry um
[Music]
there was certainly a time when like
redwood studios was like pumping out new
commander conquer games and like
changing up settings and like adding a
lot of new units and stuff where it felt
like you could really pay attention to
the rts genre and get something new out
of it every couple months or something
to look forward to
but gaming as a whole like especially on
pc has sort of blown up in so many ways
now um
because it's borrowing a lot from
consoles you know it
rts genre has kind of just disappeared
but i don't i don't think it'll ever be
like a huge mainstream success where
like an rts game is like up front but i
think it'll always be around you know
and you'll just have fewer players
um but to see off-world trading company
come out and do something that really
surprised a lot of people uh like that
would be cool to see i think more
experimentation within the genre yeah
it's weird for people
maybe like the early 2000s there were it
seemed like every property not maybe not
even early 2000s but i mean battle for
middle earth came out i actually like
those games they kind of fell too much
into the rock paper scissor formula of
you know simpler rts games
um i mean halo wars is a great like yeah
i was going to say like halo wars is is
very much the the paired down simplified
version and i actually did like the
combination of like oh here's stuff for
halo fans and here's like a simpler rts
thing i think it's good if you don't
want the barrier to entry that a lot of
rts games have right um but it's it's
just like it's not doing anything new or
different or interesting to keep your
attention yeah that's the biggest
problem for me with that yeah i was
playing homeworld finally uh late last
year and this was i mean a couple months
before halo wars 2 came out and that was
actually uh gearbox did that with
gearbox released it yeah and it was it
was a good rts it was they read they
took homeworld from space and brought it
to like the desert planet where it
supposedly started it was a prequel to
all those if you were into those games
back in the day but i mean turn-based
strategy has been flourishing like you
have x-com you have civilization and i'm
just naming for access stuff right now
but of course you have like fire emblem
you have well that's super different but
it's still like it's such a integral
part of like the rpg space
um
off the top of my head i know banner
saga just had a collection release you
should play those games you ha uh
haven't yet those are on xbox one now
yes they're about to be but
are they is did it release yet uh i
think it's on its way but like in the
next week if it's not already out yeah
so you should play those if you play on
xbox one and haven't played banner saga
one or two yet uh not rts's though i i
also just kind of
i'm wondering if there is going to be
like that renaissance year for rts like
you said it's never going to be as
widespread as shooters and last year
kind of shooters will always be around
but last year it was a lot of innovation
in that genre and like you said i don't
think rts has the same
prevalence and it's more than shooters
too it's just you know like games like
mass effect like you know just are like
bigger like grand scale games that's
maybe having an rpg element to them or
something but sort of these grander
adventures because when you're managing
like little units on a field like that
doesn't feel maybe as exciting to a lot
of people i think right off the bat you
really have to get through the barrier
to entry that cali was mentioning for a
lot of these games to experience what
makes them so great they don't have that
instant gratification yeah i think
that's probably the biggest barrier i
also think too uh i think someone in
twitch chat i think is console hot 92
had mentioned too that
with the kind of flourishing of mobas
yeah like you know dota 2 league of
legends maybe heartless uh jeez heroes
of the storm sorry hot same acronym um
maybe a lot of the people that used to
play rts games because you know that
dota basically came out from warcraft
right two or three from three um and
maybe a lot of those players have kind
of transitioned over to mobas right and
so because of that you're losing kind of
like your player base for rts games as
well yeah yeah that's a good point
yeah i mean
like i said if you pay attention there
are a decent amount of rts games coming
out and they're of high quality a few of
them i really liked homeworld if you
haven't played that yet uh if you're
like a halo fan
kind of passing fan of rts halo wars 2
might satisfy that itch yeah i mean
yeah like i gave it i didn't hate it so
it's yes
uh but for all you know
kind of waiting like go play off-world
trading company that game is awesome uh
and it's really cool
like i said it's the lead designer of uh
civilization four so he took the economy
aspects of
civilization games you played those and
kind of made it into a real-time
strategy game on mars you're founding
you're settling mars with these
corporations and it's uh
really really engaging and fun and uh
more intense than you might think in an
economy-based game anyway let us know if
we missed any rts games i'm sure we did
i know we did uh let us know which ones
you've played throughout the years which
ones you might want to see remastered
just like uh starcraft is getting
with its uh summer release coming from
blizzard again we will update you more
with the price and the actual specific
release date when we find out
all right for those just joining we are
going to get to persona 5. but right now
i want to talk about
destiny 2 a game we don't know much
about
um
yeah so here's here's tay why he came on
the show well i got starcraft you know
thanks for nothing mike i'm just joking
um we want to talk about what we want in
destiny 2 because we don't know much
about it the the leak said september 8th
release date a couple weeks ago but that
hasn't been confirmed but there has been
this teacher trailer and it's these are
image for destiny 2
um from bungie and we've been expecting
this for a while waiting for them to
actually announce it now that there's
been how many expansions three for
destiny
four
yeah dark below taken king house of
wolves
rise of iron uh
again taken king was the main one that
actually kind of revamped how the game
works so
uh
i kind of want to just get right into it
cali what do you want do you have
anything specific you want from destiny
2 or broad strokes what do you hope they
do better um i'm hoping that because
there were some things in destiny
especially vanilla
destiny and then i felt this in rise of
iron also that just felt like chores
like i felt like grinding for light in a
lot of ways
the reward started to taper off for me
um
just just because when the the
the
story is lacking kind of revisiting the
same things and trying to get into a
world can be hard for me um and i think
the teaser trailer
sort of indicated that they're leaning
into a little bit more
um like character personality or uh
world building especially because he's
talking about like
at the end it kind of zooms out and
there's there's this blown out building
yeah something because clearly happened
um so i'm hoping that that is indicative
of the
not necessarily the tone because these
cade six is very snarky i don't think
the whole game is gonna be snarky but um
nathan phillion yeah
but uh i i'm hoping that there's just a
little bit more incentive to to keep
revisiting i mean i like grinding like i
like grinding for for better loot and i
enjoy that and i mean that's why i kept
playing destiny um but i think the long
tail was a little a little bit of a
struggle for me um with that um when
taken king release it seemed like they
were like you said putting you know
revamping the systems of the game and
how it worked in terms of progression
but they also seemed like they were
putting a little more emphasis really
starting to put more emphasis on
characterization and storytelling with
those cutscenes where they characterize
k-6 what are the other vanguard leaders
names i forget
titan aikora no zavala is the titan
is the warlock okay so it seemed like
they were actually putting more effort
into telling that story because when
destiny first released when we see all
these uh trailers back before it
released in 2014
yeah september 2014
was 15. uh before it released a few
years ago
we kind of saw
like oh people made halo and marathon
are going into this mmo space that
combines with shooters and it's going to
be our solar system kind of like a mass
effect of um
you know like a reimagined
solar system we live in and it was
really appealing but then when we played
this game it seemed like there wasn't as
much to it as we hoped or at least we
didn't really fully understand what it
was like they kept saying this is in
many ways going to be a platform for us
to build upon and i think
those among us who are excited for
different reasons
kept saying well i would still like to
see them explore some cool storytelling
in this because i like i like halo's
storytelling
yeah me too and i just i love sci-fi
storytelling in general and i think
there's just so much potential there and
i
love the the feel of shooting in this
game and that i i want to combine that
with a little something a little bit
more substantial and i think like i said
i think maybe the last episode or two
episodes ago on the lobby um i think you
know rectifying the stuff with uh
dinklebot
uh
indicates that they they they kind of
figured that out and they started to
take steps in that direction so i'm i
feel like that is promising for destiny
2. yeah that makes sense they went
through a good year of just quality of
life changes as well as knowing as you
had as you had mentioned cali that their
story was a little weak and they're
trying to revamp that and i think they
did a good job with that again with as
mike said too uh you know with taking
king there was like this huge kind of
push and that's kind of what got you
back in the game too was that there was
so much more kind of interacting with
the npcs there was more just story there
and i think and hope that they've
learned a lot through this this year
that they found a nice kind of balance
for both the hardcore and the more
casual player um aaron would love to
have some type of raid make uh raid
matchmaking which is not in the game yet
which is debatable which is debatable
because i'm on one side of the fence i
wouldn't want to do the raid with
strangers but but what they what they
could do is they could do it like wow
where they simplify the raid um
for the raid making group but then they
don't get as good of a reward for it
um so then they get like a lower tier
version of like
if you did it normally with your friends
or something like that
you didn't have any friends who played
i was gonna stop it
it would be sad if you didn't have any
friends but the thing though is at least
with that they can still experience the
raid albeit maybe not the the full
version of it but something similar
still get the raid experience which i
think is very important to the game the
raid is like super key i don't think you
can skip the raid yeah if you really
want to get the full experience um and
that was what the the bright spot for
rise of iron for me was the raid i
really enjoyed it um but
i don't
i don't know i like that idea i would
get really nervous i don't want to do
the radio change well we'll see i mean
just more matchmaking in general too
because you know nightfall and stuff
like that i don't
uh you know those things are things that
you might have trouble doing um on your
own but at the same time right now they
kind of
got around that problem by having lfg
stuff on on online that you can then
look for other people and generally
people are pretty serviceable they know
what they're doing right so
and i do think that would help
maybe more casual players like if you
don't have a group that's like dedicated
to raiding like oh we're going to raid
like every wednesday or whatever it is
it would be helpful to because if you're
a casual player who's not going to do
that you aren't necessarily looking for
the best loot anyway so
i mean that is that was the biggest pain
point i think for some of the people in
the office was
they did most of what the game had to
offer and they wanted to do the raid but
then it was hard because it would take
somebody to be like okay i'm going to
try to assemble this raid yeah it's a
commitment yeah it's a commitment it's a
time commitment or you have somebody
like you need to carry somebody through
the raid so they can get better gear so
you can properly do the raid and it's
yeah there's just like a lot of
complications yeah but like i said
they've added a lot of good stuff so
like everything they've added also for
this last kind of like hurrah turn in
terms of like their content drop um for
destiny one has been good like i think
all that all the quality of life stuff
enhances the game a lot better than what
it was like that vanilla destiny where
you used to have to you know grind
materials like mmo style we walk around
and pick up like relic iron and stuff
like that which is super annoying now
it's like way easier it's just a better
kind of experience to not
totally waste your time i guess they
respect your time a little bit more i
also definitely want the app to make a
comeback because i love being able to
switch gear like super easily yeah i
have to do the vault garbage i love it i
love the app i used to when i first
started playing destiny i would like go
to work and like just be on the app
looking like reading the lore because i
like couldn't stop thinking about
destiny
yeah
if you played on nintendo switch you
could use the app on the tablet
[Music]
i wish that would come out on switch
no but never maybe what if it comes out
on pc and you can now get those people
that maybe don't have a console and
wanted to play it
and maybe you can somehow play with pc i
mean i know windows sorry i know xbox
one has done a good job of like cross
play with
windows and kind of right so it's kind
of there i know street fighter 5 has it
with ps4 and pc kind of so
it'll be interesting if they can figure
that out because i think that would kind
of expand the player base do you guys
expect there's going to be like sort of
a a small gimmicky vr component not like
a huge mission but like
try on your gear
look at this little area i mean
i'd be shocked if it didn't have it i
think it really i think it will have i'm
not talking about anything substantial
or like this is a selling point for the
game well i mean because there is like
you get
content first on ps4 maybe there's a psv
already we know that for sure though i
mean with destiny like with the original
current
but like
um you're talking about two out of three
platforms that's coming out on have vr
support right yeah and they're obviously
not going to try to sell the game or
have it live and die by its vr support
because i don't think it'll be
substantial but
yeah i'd be shocked if they didn't try
this a little bit of something to give
people just like just a little taste of
you know like a different way of looking
at this world and sort of being within
it
last question uh let's put money on it
because you guys don't i don't think
oh a bet yeah no i think funny you
should mention bets
um eric tay yeah
before tayden king came out oh my god
this is stupid uh you and i had a bet to
see who can get to level 40 the new uh
level cap first yeah uh so jean-luc's
gonna roll something here this is me and
you playing
i believe he's gonna bring audio up
uh so here's irish axe that's me
of course that's you here we have bounty
saved up
and
apologies if i'm talking over this
because i don't i don't know if there's
audio right now jean-luc is there audio
playing for the stream
dead silence yeah uh so this is the
stream we did
and i turned a bunch of these in you're
like holy [ __ ] i just got to level 37 in
like 10 seconds and me and tay had a
steak dinner riding on who would get to
level 40 first
and
yeah cut away from him
oh my god he didn't know nothing
all right well i won uh we ended up i
ended up because i got to it so easy
that within like 10 minutes we turned in
bounties we had saved up before 10k came
out and i got to level 40
right before you only because you're
like i could crush you right now get to
level 40. so then i just like started i
know you know what i was one who had
that i want to have i never got steak
i got you a sandwich though i bought you
lunch was it a steak sandwich yeah
really i don't know if you got me sushi
which is fine yeah sushi is a good
alternative i think so we we didn't
think
that turning in all our bounties would
just get us to level 40. yeah but
somehow it did that also you have the
stupid cloak that gives plus 10 percent
except you had it too you i didn't wear
it yes you did they gave it to you at
the beginning of taken king you
didn't just use this
for your for your new subclass yes um
yeah whatever but yeah i did lose this
also if you just watch this another fun
fact quality of life thing is you know
how you had to go here to turn in your
boundaries you have to do that anymore
you can do that in your menu no no you
had to turn in year one bounties to him
oh oh okay um anyway okay i just wanted
his face once again it's been two years
since that happened
uh it's actually funny i was watching
the stream we both look pretty young
ah shut up
what
uh anyway okay sweet so that's destiny 2
what we hope we're going to get out of
it and what they're going to learn from
the expansions that destiny released uh
again
it was a rumored september 8th release
date we don't have that confirmed yet
march 30th but he's going to be making
the announcement uh that's the deal
right that's tomorrow that's today's the
29th yeah yeah my sister's birthday
march mm-hmm now okay cool so tomorrow a
couple days after your birthday yeah
that sucks but six years prior
oh keep an eye on gamespot.com
for the announcement or whatever is
coming tomorrow the stream
is that what it is deed you can be doing
a stream no i think it's just like a
trailer trailer trailer cool yeah uh so
that will be on gamespot.com you can go
check that out and stay tuned here as
until september when we will tell you
how this game is
maybe i feel like i feel like we'll see
something at e3 i don't know if we'll
get like hands-on or anything like that
but i wouldn't be shocked if we saw
something at e3 we have to right thank
you yeah so
yeah i guarantee oh
you're on the hook i don't know why i
did that
all right
the game of the hour the release date or
the the release embargoes went up this
morning review embargo
it's the same thing
no no review embargoes went off this
morning our very own lucy james over in
the uk reviewed persona 5.
uh last week we talked about
could this be your first in the series
i'm back to answer that question yeah it
can wow this is my first game of the
series i'm really liking it i played it
until 4am yeah he came in the office
he's like i love persona it's so cool i
like ripped my clothes off and started
chanting no just kidding um
i want to ask you guys what your
personas would be uh but we'll get into
that of course uh anyway
this game uh released in japan how long
ago
i want to say
last
think it was september december everyone
went to tgs and came back with copies
yeah and everything that they were
saying based on that version was
phenomenal i can't read japanese
yeah
i think
i don't know
um
but yeah this game is fun i mean
i like it a lot like i said last week on
the lobby i don't know the series i
really like uh i mean what surprised you
about it
uh it actually at first i was kind of
like i don't get why people like this i
mean it was fun uh i do like i have a
few things i want to talk about actually
uh it's subverting a lot of my
expectations of
um i know sometimes you think this is a
problematic term jrpg i think it's a
problematic term i think it's a dumb
term okay well
for the intense of this conversation
i like
like eastern rpgs that style as opposed
to oh my god that's worse
i like jrpgs um
i i enjoy
you know like turn-based kind of grind
heavy rpgs i don't play them as much as
i would like to because you know like
natural job we have to play a lot of
games but they're very time consuming
exactly and i actually think this game
makes that grind interesting and fun so
uh for those who don't know
there are like kind of two sides to
persona games i mean cal you played a
lot of these you wanna well yeah i mean
there's the the
traditional jrpg going into like a
dungeon sort of area and doing a
turn-based battle and then there's the
slice of life a little more anime like
you're a high school student and after
school you get to kind of choose your
activities and that's been expanded a
lot in persona five there's more stuff
you can do
um so yeah there's like two two sides to
it and you can uh
you know get to know
your compatriots i don't know why that
was the only word i could think
confidence sexy friends but they call
them confidants in the game yeah cool
high school friends
um
and so i i like that kind of balance i i
think i said this last week but i love
slice of life um and i i just love
having kind of that uh not respite
because i don't think the rest of it is
like a chore or anything but just having
a step back to breathe a little bit and
explore tokyo and and
get into the world a little bit more uh
in between you know
what what you're converting people's
hearts
you're fixing bullies and stuff
yeah whole thing yeah like again to
clarify uh lucy james who reviewed it
for us she has loved the series and or
she's knowledgeable about the series and
she knows what persona 5 does
differently for more in-depth look at
that please read the review watch the
review i don't have that same history so
i wanted to approach it with you guys
kind of asking me questions about my
first experience with the series and the
one thing i like about it when you
mention those slice of life that social
aspect i didn't really enjoy high school
in real life so why would i care about
doing laundry and you know being this
problematic teenager and going to high
school in tokyo because anime high
school is where it's at but this game is
completely i didn't know how dark it
would get like right off the bat right
away it's extremely dark yeah i didn't
know that i see john lew can mention
john luke knows personally he's like
yeah people see this it's a very stylish
game and like acid jazz soundtrack and
then when you get into battles it's kind
of hard very colorful and like i mean
you can see now like the the ui and the
the hud and the menus are all like
super stylized in this i don't even know
how to peel away the superficial layer
and you find a game that touches on
things that most games like don't yeah
it's like really deep human connections
and suicide and fun stuff like that
and i you mentioned those slice of life
things and i was like i wish i want to
play this game but i don't care about
that stuff but i actually think
because that stuff can be a grind but
in the sense that you're spending a lot
of time right so it almost reminded me
and this is a dumb comparison but this
is my first thing off the bat i was
explaining this to someone in our office
who really likes grand theft auto like a
lot of people when you are doing a heist
in grand theft auto you go around
preparing for it right and as thieves in
the metaverse kind of like the matrix
world and persona you are going into
palaces these manifestations these uh
psychological manifestations of people's
inner desires and personalities and
you're trying to find their treasure
which will is essentially their their
core yes of their desires which
in like i said in this game some
people's desires that they act on are
kind of messed up and so you're kind of
exposing these bad people in the real
world by going into their psychological
metaverse and
as thieves
you're preparing for these so like
heists so to speak and that's where the
high school stuff actually interested me
because i was you have a time limit
right you have like two weeks and i was
saying okay do i want to go work my
part-time job and get 2 800 yen so i can
buy a new weapon tomorrow or save up for
a new armor later on or do i want to go
increase my
proficiency by going to the batting
cages or to the gym so then uh later on
when i have the chance to use that that
social
stat will help me in the metaverse
time management is such a big part of
that like being able to maximize your
time for what you want to do is so
important um and a lot of
i mean that's
something i really love uh and it sounds
i don't know it almost sounds like too
nerdy but i'm just like i want to make
sure i do everything perfectly that i
almost get like i have to take a break
and really think about it yeah um and so
it's like even more time consuming than
the 100 hours it took everybody to beat
the game for review yeah i think they're
saying average is like 105. yeah jesus
um
and that
seems like a lot but i want to keep
playing it for other reasons but i do
like that there is a time limit before
you have to go into the palaces or else
you just get game over
i mean you're doing board stuff and
you're getting to know these characters
which i want to get into as well but
i think that the fact there is a time
limit on these things that i would
otherwise consider grinding makes them a
little more intense knowing that you're
about to go into this person's palace or
that dude kamashita yeah i don't wanna
spoil anything um but these are all
memorable people already and i've only
played eight hours of this game
um
i think that the characters are also
very engaging but at first i was like oh
these just seem like jrpg tropes they
seem like rpg tropes in general and then
they start subverting that actually with
uh you have like the punk like rebel one
um ryuji
and then you have the main character is
kind of the reticent
uh
sarcastic
one i named mine shooter mcgavin um
and then you have on lady on who right
now and then you have a morgana the cat
and
it's pretty cool everybody has guns
right here and i was what is going on
but apparently in the real world those
are model guns but because you're in the
metaverse people see them they think
they're real and they manifest as real
guns in the metaverse and it kind of
gets into some cool like matrix
alternate reality stuff where
obviously people who know the series
know that your persona will kind of
flourish in the metaverse p you're
saying some a lot of times it's like the
suppressed part of people's real world
personality that comes out
yes
yeah yeah at least at the beginning yeah
that's sort of like like your stand in
like jojo's bizarre adventure
like the actual oh sorry no no i was
gonna say the actual storyline is about
a lot of these characters and
because it's high school
i actually think that setting fits
because there are rumors floating around
and everybody has these surface level
assumptions about people and i kind of
fell into that trap i saw on
and i had these assumptions or at least
people had these rumors you kind of
overhear these incidental conversations
and then people have heard these rumors
about your character and people hear
these things about ryuji and how he's a
thug and a like a rebel and then i found
out stuff that about ryuji's home life
and i found out stuff about anne that
actually plays a big part of her
character how people take her beauty and
just don't look past it and then in
the metaverse her like sexuality
actually her her persona is very sexual
uh person it's like almost like it kind
of sounds like a dominatrix and it's
like i think the real world she
suppresses that stuff because she feels
like she has to and that is when it gets
interesting it takes these character
archetypes and actually starts
taking what my expectations were then
based on these rumors and these things
that they were saying but then i got to
know them through that slice of life
stuff and i was like holy [ __ ] this is
actually really cool to see how that
manifests and changes in the metaverse
yeah i was going to say i mean she's one
of the most relatable characters for me
so far i'm not very far in um because of
that and i relate to that a lot
and i think persona in general and
especially persona 5 does a great job of
of making you want to do the mundane
things because it enriches everything um
getting to know the characters and like
developing characters is such a strong
suit um and i think that the main like
having to go in and see somebody's core
like what's at the core of them is is so
cool and like such a good way to do that
um that it like i mean because you were
saying you didn't you weren't thinking
you would like the slice of life stuff
but i think it does a good job of making
people who aren't into that more into it
i mean like i was already like so stoked
to i'm like i'm gonna go to anime high
school i can't wait i'm gonna take a
test oh yeah um but um i just think it's
so so intelligently done
yeah i mean it was
i really actually liked that i kind of
started appreciating that
those social so a lot of it's quantified
obviously you get like a rank for that
uh person's persona so the more the
closer you get to them the more you
learn about them it'll go up and you'll
learn new skills through that that you
can use in combat which we can talk
about the combat um
but again the writing was enough to it's
like melodramatic in a lot of parts but
it is very anime it's i mean there are
anime cut scenes at certain parts oh
they're beautiful they're really good
beautifully animated i mean they're
already
i i knew they would be because there are
persona anime yeah already but yeah i
just uh i was so delighted it like opens
with i mean i like that you're kind of
thrust into this immediate like foot
race opening um and starts like the game
starts immediately and then there's just
like beautiful anime lights and scenery
i just i love it yeah i don't know the
series but apparently persona 4 took a
while to get in like it was so very slow
at the beginning yes five just kind of
throws you right into it but it's kind
of uh it dials it back yeah yeah yeah
for a second but yeah for the slow burn
is what or the slow start i just i
couldn't get into it but this game
definitely it
it invigorates you and makes you very
curious what's happening both for the
conflicts of presence and the spectacle
at the same time
yeah very good at the start how do you
guys feel about the voiceovers
because i find them to be a little bit
grating
there is a patch for japanese voices
like out i cannot play i don't like
playing jrpgs with english voiceover
especially if the if the setting is supe
what i don't know i thumbs up that
because i agree with it especially if
the setting is if we're in tokyo and
we're in a clearly japanese high school
environment and everybody's names are
japanese uh they pronounce uh sakamoto
as sakamoto so yeah that's super
annoying i've noticed that so much
and yeah so i'm excited to be able to
switch to japanese video i it's not like
hurting the experience for me but it is
like it ryuji's voice is really kind of
rough yeah i thought so he reminded me
of like an old ninja turtles cartoon
so that happens a lot with anime dubs of
um thug-ish characters like the thug
archetype um there's actually another
anime where the thug character's name is
ryuji um that i'm thinking of where the
dub voices are just like they try to
lean too hard into the anime archetype
and so it just comes off as so grating
um and i just i think it's like
something that gets lost in translation
literally uh where it's like oh
like
like for example when uh osaka ben gets
translated into like southern dialect in
english it's like
that's not quite right right and that's
the sentiment is there but the execution
doesn't make sense yeah it's like okay
we get that osaka supposed to be like
back woods like in
theory but the southern accent doesn't
work and so it's very similar in english
is that where the main character's
supposed to be from
no no no that's just an example of
things that in dubbed uh
anything that's been translated from
japanese to english yeah um when you're
trying to translate something like
yakuza dialect
uh
when you try to sound like a new york
gangster it's just not right well and
there's a quality that especially with
yakuza like the rolling of the r's and
all of that and the roughness
like yeah like it's why why change it
you know preserve it even if the
language is different because i think
there's some sentiment behind that stuff
yeah that you need yeah absolutely we
have a crazy amount of time left but i
do want to get into the dungeon crawling
combat
so how far are you into it i'm not very
far honestly i played like four
different games yesterday i'm juggling
okay so i've done the first
palace like dungeon crawl i've gotten
the first uh treasure the treasures are
the core of their desire personalities
really quickly it is notable that
previous persona games were procedurally
generated dungeons and this only has one
area that's procedurally generated
mostly for grinding yeah for grant the
grinding area it's like mementos i think
yeah um this is they're all like hand uh
crafted dungeons yeah and i do like it
they
the combat is
they do it cool i didn't realize how
hard this can get if you don't if you
don't prepare for the palace the crawls
you if you don't have enough items
especially i've been uh for like action
points i've been low on so i've been
using melee hey guys limited ammo we got
a rap we don't have a ton of time left
like i said but
um i think combat's great i love uh
fusing persona for the main character
you can actually um
create new persona you'd have to kill
old parts of your persona to fuse them
with new ones to make
uh you know like different you know kind
of classes of persona and get different
abilities and everything just to wrap i
guess probably my favorite thing is the
negotiation stuff that you have to do
when you get to like play with demons
and like sort of figure out like how you
can take advantage of them but they
often turn the tables and take advantage
of you because they think yeah because
you think that you know everything yeah
you can say give me an item it's a hold
up if you stun everybody in the party
using elemental weaknesses or getting
critical hits or using weapons when
they're weak to them everybody party
like goes and points the guns at them
and say give me an item give me money or
lend me your power if you don't have
that persona yet and they'll say i have
to see if it would be a good fit or
something like that and the higher level
ones will ask more
riddles than actual just flat out show
you their personality so this one guy i
can tell he's just mischievous so i just
did and you have like three response
choices and if you get if you make a
bond with them right there then you can
get their persona down the road fuse it
with another one to make it stronger and
i really like those or you can just do
an all-out attack when everybody just
[ __ ] destroys them
uh yeah like i said you can go watch the
more in-depth video review uh and read
the review by lucy james uh her and
timur put a lot of time in the game
miguel concepcion here played a lot of
it and he's been doing a lot of guide
stuff and capturing for us and he's
gonna we're gonna have more persona 5
coverage on gamespot.com so stay tuned
for that and go play this game
it's fun
cool
that was a good show that was the show
welcome back thank you welcome back to
the lobby thanks uh when destiny's
announced we'll bring you no it's joking
we'll bring you on soon yeah that could
be next week no yes not happening uh i
would normally ask you what you guys
have going on but like i said we have uh
100 pence is coming in in half an hour
we're going to be streaming from
gamespot uh on gamespot twitch and
youtube uh mlb 17 with the right fielder
for the san francisco giants 100 pence
who also happens to stream on twitch and
play a lot of games so he knows what
he's talking about and i'm sure he finds
it pretty cool that he's in video games
now uh but they're also him and nick
margarita here at gamespot are going to
be
creating characters and playing the road
to the show mode and also the retro mode
which is kind of like limited interface
and also like two buttons i think uh it
looks pretty cool
but yeah so stay tuned for that and then
tomorrow triforce pete and rob will be
playing zelda breath of the wild for an
hour you know it uh rob handler and i
will be streaming titanfall 2's new dlc
tomorrow so we have a lot of streams
this week
uh again persona 5 review is up we'll
have more destiny news when it's coming
out we'll have more starcraft news once
the prize is announced uh and when the
release date is announced for this
summer and also follow gamespot if you
play xbox one games and you want to play
mafia 3 or just get that collector's
edition there is the new free trial for
the game and also the dlc this right
here retweet game spots tweet shiva will
be tweeting it and
cool thanks so much for joining us as
always
i'm gonna go play more persona uh watch
that mlb stream
thanks for joining me everyone cheers
best girl oh my god thanks for joining
us everyone we'll see you next week
[Music]
do i do